je pense que la
coïncidence avec l'omicron
est évidemment une coïncidence, mais j'ai
planifié avant la prochaine vague parce que
je savais qu'il y aurait d'autres
médias médiatiques dans tout le pays et que les gens
voudraient évidemment venir
vous savez pour le vaccin
que j'avais  un peu paniqué quand j'ai entendu
parler de la nouvelle variante omicron donc c'était
vous savez mais terrifiant pas parce que
j'avais hâte de voir ma famille et
mes amis pendant la saison des fêtes et quand
j'ai vu la campagne de vaccination aujourd'hui, vous
savez que c'était un peu  un soulagement parce
qu'alors je pouvais simplement entrer,
ils ont fait l'inscription et tout
était plus pratique et accessible en tant
que comité de santé, nous nous sommes mobilisés de
porte en porte et nous
avions des brochures dans
toute la communauté ainsi que sur les
réseaux sociaux, nous utilisons notre social
plateformes médiatiques pour
diffuser les informations que
vous